I'm a weapon of Mao's discussion
come on buddy this is gonna be a stealth
mission don't tell me you're scared
there's nothing safer than a dark alley
ah just a lovable little dolly okay
that's a little creepy
this is bad it's been nice knowing your
buddy
you scared us cute little guy Boop some
call me killed
Oh got it my name is mr. Fang I was
cursed with this big adorable eyes and
this fuzzy little buddy why are you here
I need your help to take back the park
this Park has everything we need but the
mayor wants to destroy everything I got
bigger plants and trees an amusement
park they're going to destroy the park
that's not good don't you see were all
animals we need to look out for each
other we are in get together if you want
to stop the merit is going it squirrel
sees it's going to pick everyone when
should we do try to not get killed I'll
try but I can't make any promises
individually we might be tiny but
together with giant don't roll over I
don't know how I'm not classically
trained don't get a boys I'm a weapon of
both discussion drink
thank you little rodents if they stop me
wow this is gonna be fun
[Music]
meet my new friend mr. Fang that reminds
me
don't call him cannonball you'll excuse
me I got to get back to slacking off
precious we talked about this it's hard
to respect your personal space when it
tastes like peanut butter look at all of
you lazy boy holding back take it easy
Andy it's not like the nut shops can
explode oh the peanut butter was in
there I'll find a new place even better
than the nut shop pretty as a picture
perfect Liberty Park generate zero
profit I got bigger plants and trees and
it is hard they're gonna destroy the
park the fat guy was designing shovel
how much damage could he do
oh I get it tiny shovel was a symbolic
gesture this park is worth fighting for
I got this let's see you drive down
I'm good but you guys get the next one
my crazy plans don't work they'll follow
you anywhere surely you can do it it's
all you know it's not all me if you want
to stop these guys it's gonna fix
everything - lets go get off what are
you doing roll over I don't know how I'm
not classically trained work that long
you like it the very existence of this
game offends me we were overrun by
enemies mangy little rodents don't get
it boys
have got to be a safety violation
[Music]
oh sorry
you